he got up to me
and he stabbed me in the back
and then he ran off
speaking from her hospital bed after she
was attacked on the Las Vegas Strip
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock I'm Sasha Loftus we're learning
more about Anna Westby a showgirl and
one of eight people stabbed on the Strip
This Week Westby who has a punctured
lung was one of six people hurt two were
also killed including fellow showgirl
Maris diogiovanni Madison Kimbrough is
live on the Las Vegas Strip tonight with
more and we do want to warn you this
story may be disturbing to some Madison
Maris along with seven others were
damaged and attacked here on the Strip
happened just before noon on Thursday
right here as you can see near wind now
I've been in contact with mares's family
who has shared some pictures you're
about to see describing her as the life
of any Gathering
Iran as fast as I could with them and
then I think he got me
um
I didn't feel
I didn't feel that he stabbed me until I
got to the Wingate victims speaking out
and those all over still reeling after
Thursday's attack on the Las Vegas Strip
six people are still recovering while
two people are dead of the two dead 47
year old Brent Allen Hallett and 30 year
old Maris de Giovanni Maris a showgirl
on the Las Vegas Strip wasn't alone as
other victims who lived to tell their
story share the terrifying encounter
we've got the knife and he stabbed
mirrors in the heart
and then Victoria ran
and he chased Victoria
and he stabbed her in the back
embarrassed when she got stabbed she ran
and I ran in the same direction as her
and she collapsed Westby stating that
she was then stabbed in the midst of
running Westby was by mayor's side
through the whole ordeal as they were
rushed to the hospital marriage to
Giovanni's family sharing these photos
with eight news now stating that she was
a light to the world originally from
Spokane Washington she always saw the
best in people always gave them a chance
and always accepted people for who they
were
and as for Westby the woman interviewed
from her hospital bed she made it clear
that she will not be back on the Strip
anytime soon as she just wants to
recover and says that now she questions
unfortunately everything live from the
strip Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now